the tsa says it counted more than 7
million air travelers between
thursday and sunday a huge jump over
last year but still
24 percent less than memorial day 2019
before the pandemic even so many
businesses are scrambling to meet
expected demand when the summer
gets really busy mololengi is at point
pleasant beach that's in new jersey mola
good morning to you on the boardwalk
oh good morning tony it was a busy
holiday weekend here on the jersey shore
for businesses you know folks are
still waking up right now so things are
getting into gear but this boardwalk
was bustling over memorial day but still
we spoke to one family business who says
they can't quite get back to normal
because they can't find enough employees
to hire
after a difficult year crowds on the
jersey shore are a welcome
site for local businesses like
restaurants and hotels hoping to
maximize the summer season
this has maybe been the toughest start
to a to a season
absolutely christina ronauro and her
family have owned and operated the white
sands resort and spa in point pleasant
beach new jersey for 35 years
they typically hire about 150 seasonal
employees to work at the resort
and restaurants but this year are having
trouble
we really have only a third
of what we normally hire third a third
we're really really short-handed
everyone including renouro is working
double time she said she's posted help
wanted ads all over the web and has
increased the starting wage
from twelve dollars an hour to fifteen
dollars an hour
but there are few applicants we're at
hundred percent we have waiting lists
for the first time in ten years we just
don't have the staff to turn the rooms
over as fast as we'd like to
and they're not alone businesses across
the country are desperately looking for
workers
from this bakery in philadelphia i don't
have help
i had help they went on to other jobs
to this los angeles restaurant it's been
a tough ride
it's been difficult we have an
unprecedented hiring crisis going on
right now
new jersey business and industry
association president and ceo
michelle sukerka says the challenging
job market has been a perfect storm
people struggling with child care
foreign students unable to get work
visas
and entry level seasonal work not paying
as well as unemployment benefits
they're pulling out all the stops we
have sign up bonuses
we have you know free food free
entertainment
a lot of incentive going on
[Music]
because they're short staff so many of
these businesses have had to make
adjustments the white sands resort
where we visited is closing off some of
their rooms at the moment they're
closing the restaurant for a couple of
days a week so missing out on some
potential revenue
there but still anthony they say they
are hopeful for the summer
i hope so too mola and point pleasant
beach new jersey thanks